Hi everyone, it's Caitlin Luna, host of Speaking of Psychology. This episode was recorded live during APA 2019, our annual convention that was held in Chicago this year. I was away on maternity leave during that time, so my colleague Dr. Russ Schilling was a guest host. We hope you enjoy the episode. Welcome. This is Speaking of Psychology from the APA convention. I'm the host for this session, Russell Schilling. I'm the chief scientific officer for APA. And I'll let my two guests introduce themselves. My name is Caitlin Ruse.
大家好，我是《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的主持人凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。本期节目是在我们今年于芝加哥举办的年度大会——2019年美国心理学会（APA）大会期间现场录制的。当时我正在休产假，所以由我的同事拉塞尔·席林（Dr. Russ Schilling）博士担任客座主持。希望大家喜欢这期节目。欢迎收听。这里是来自APA大会的《心理学谈话》。我是本场节目的主持人拉塞尔·席林。我是APA的首席科学官。现在请我的两位嘉宾做一下自我介绍。我叫凯特琳·鲁斯（Caitlin Ruse）。
I am a fourth year PhD student at Michigan Technological University, studying higher level cognition in games. My name is Sean Doherty. I'm an associate professor at Emory Riddle Aeronautical University in the Human Factors in Behavioral Neuroscience Department. I am also currently the program chair for Division 21 here at APA, which is the applied experimental and engineering psychology division.
我是密歇根理工大学四年级的博士生，研究方向是游戏中的高阶认知。我叫肖恩·多尔蒂（Sean Doherty）。我是安柏瑞德航空航天大学人类因素与行为神经科学系的副教授。目前我还是APA第21分会（应用实验与工程心理学分会）的项目主席。
We'll leave it there. Okay. And today what we're going to be discussing is the psychology of e-sports, why it's relevant to psychology and why we should care as psychologists about e-sports. And so I'll start out with just asking that question of our panelists. So why should psychologists be concerned with e-sports? Psychologists should be concerned with e-sports for many reasons. Regardless of what discipline you're a part of, we have many people of many disciplines here at
我们就先介绍到这里。好的。今天我们要讨论的是电子竞技心理学，为什么它与心理学相关，以及作为心理学家我们为什么要关注电子竞技。那么，我就先向我们的嘉宾提出这个问题。为什么心理学家应该关注电子竞技？心理学家应该关注电子竞技的原因有很多。无论你属于哪个学科，我们这里汇集了许多学科的人士，
APA. And so whether it's the mental part, so disorders, abnormal psychology, stress management, performance psychology, coming from sports psychology, development of a culture, communication, team dynamics. There are many facets of e-sports that I think are fascinating, if not maybe confusing to a lot of psychologists, and it hasn't really been delved into very much. So I think it's an open field that I'm calling upon many psychologists to explore further. Okay. Well, it's so open, in fact, because it's relatively brand new. So just to give a little bit of context, e-sports involves the use of video games in competition with other video game players. So just as in traditional sports, you may have one team competing against another one. It's the same thing for e-sports, but we're utilizing video games where you have one team competing against another within a video game context. So that's what we're talking about here with e-sports. And so this is a relatively new area for research in that e-sports is relatively new as a discipline itself, which means that there's not a lot of research on it, which provides a lot of opportunity.
在APA大会上。所以，无论是心理层面，比如心理障碍、变态心理学、压力管理、表现心理学（源自运动心理学）、文化发展、沟通，还是团队动力学。我认为电子竞技有很多方面非常引人入胜，甚至可能让许多心理学家感到困惑，而且目前还没有得到深入研究。所以我认为这是一个开放的领域，我呼吁更多的心理学家去进一步探索。好的。事实上，它之所以如此开放，是因为它相对较新。为了提供一点背景信息，电子竞技涉及在与其他电子游戏玩家的竞争中使用电子游戏。就像传统体育一样，你可能会有一支队伍与另一支队伍竞争。电子竞技也是如此，但我们利用的是电子游戏，即在一场电子游戏背景下，一支队伍与另一支队伍进行竞争。这就是我们所说的电子竞技。因此，这是一个相对较新的研究领域，因为电子竞技本身作为一个学科还比较新，这意味着关于它的研究还不多，这提供了很多机会。
Well, I know all three of us have been active in games. So in my background, I've helped create games. I was a sound designer on a major title. I funded at various times, various educational and, Games for Impact, so really been part of the culture. A big fan of Portal, my favorite video game, we have to get that out there. Absolutely. So what are the differences you see between traditional gaming in those contexts and e-sports?
我知道我们三个人都积极参与过游戏。就我的背景而言，我参与过游戏的制作。我曾是一款大型游戏的声音设计师。我曾在不同时期资助过各种教育类游戏和“影响力游戏”（Games for Impact），所以确实是这个文化的一部分。我是《传送门》（Portal）的忠实粉丝，这是我最喜欢的电子游戏，必须得提一下。当然。那么，你认为传统游戏在这些背景下与电子竞技有什么区别？
You hit on a few of them just now, but how do you see the overall differences? I think a lot of times there's a lot of environmental pressure coming on the side of the professionals as they are literally being paid on a stage to perform well and they are expected to perform well. They're expected to face their fans, the media with a certain professional face. They're expected to be professional. They're expected to perform both internally within the team and maybe externally if they attend events and things. So I think that in and of itself, those pressures that have given a lot of young players because the average age of e-sports players
你刚才提到了其中的几点，但你认为整体差异在哪里？我认为很多时候，职业选手面临着巨大的环境压力，因为他们确实是在舞台上拿钱表演，并且被期望表现出色。他们被期望以一种专业的面貌面对粉丝和媒体。他们被期望表现得专业。他们被期望在团队内部以及如果参加活动等外部场合都能有良好的表现。所以我认为，仅此一点，这些压力给许多年轻选手带来了很大影响，因为电子竞技选手的平均年龄
has actually is slowly rising and I say very slowly. I think it is now 24 years old. So typically, esports players are between 18 and 28. Yes, there are people outside of that range, but players typically are very young. So these pressures of maybe things that people in other careers would experience
实际上正在缓慢上升，我说的是非常缓慢。我认为现在是24岁。所以通常情况下，电子竞技选手的年龄在18到28岁之间。是的，也有超出这个范围的人，但选手通常非常年轻。所以这些压力，可能是其他职业中更成熟的人在日常生活中会经历的事情，
on a day-to-day basis, maybe that are more mature in development, they're experiencing this in a very high pressure situation. So this may be very new to them and very difficult. Compared to maybe more casual players, and I say casual in quotes, maybe non-professionals, but there are definitely competitive players and maybe more casual players, but they're not quite at the level of the esports professionals. So I certainly agree that there are different levels of play.
他们却是在一个高压环境下经历的。所以这对他们来说可能非常新，也非常困难。与那些更休闲的玩家相比——我把“休闲”加了引号，也许是非职业玩家，但他们绝对是竞技型玩家，可能还有更休闲的玩家，但他们还没有达到电子竞技职业选手的水平。所以我当然同意，游戏存在不同的水平。
And so you may have different views or different pressure. at those different levels. But if we're talking about professional players, you're talking about just like sports teams, they may be playing in front of hundreds of thousands of spectators. Their performance may be streamed to people watching online. And so their performance is under scrutiny all the time, just like standard sports teams typically are.
因此，在这些不同的水平上，你可能会有不同的观点或面临不同的压力。但如果我们谈论的是职业选手，就像运动队一样，他们可能在成千上万的观众面前比赛。他们的表现可能会被直播给在线观看的人。所以他们的表现一直处于审视之下，就像标准的运动队通常那样。
And so there's a lot of pressures. And so while Russ, you and I may have grown up on largely solo play games because we didn't, you know, back in our day, we didn't have multiplayer. No. Nowadays there is much more integration of coordination between people and in teams and play through e-sports. And so I think that's a big difference that has been growing over time. Yeah. Well, I think a lot of our listeners to this will be familiar with some. of the news items out for the professional leagues.
所以压力很大。虽然拉塞尔，你和我可能是在很大程度上玩单机游戏长大的，因为你知道，在我们那个年代，我们没有多人游戏。没有。如今，通过电子竞技，人与人之间以及团队内部的协调整合程度要高得多。所以我认为这是一个随着时间推移一直在增长的巨大差异。是的。嗯，我想我们的大多数听众会对职业联赛的一些新闻有所了解。
What are we seeing in the schools? I mean, so what is the overall, I know you've helped create a league? So what's that like on the non-professional levels? What are we seeing out there for this? I know a lot of universities have reported university benefits to integrating an e-sports program. For example, increase in recruitment,
我们在学校里看到了什么？我的意思是，整体情况如何？我知道你参与创建了一个联赛？那么在非职业层面是什么样的？我们在这方面看到了什么？我知道许多大学已经报告了整合电子竞技项目带来的大学效益。例如，增加招生，
increase in enrollment, obviously. And in a general increase, I believe, and student well-being and happiness across campus, especially across maybe individuals who are international students. My university has many international students. And in my survey that I sent out an actually e-sport climate survey,
显然，入学人数增加了。而且我相信，校园内学生的整体福祉和幸福感也有所提高，特别是对于那些国际学生。我的大学有很多国际学生。在我发出的电子竞技环境调查中，
many students that were international students felt it would be an excellent opportunity to integrate this program into our university because esports is such a worldwide thing. It is such an international thing. It brings people of different countries together, different backgrounds. It doesn't matter who you are.
许多国际学生认为将这个项目整合到我们的大学是一个绝佳的机会，因为电子竞技是一个全球性的事物。它是一个非常国际化的事物。它将不同国家、不同背景的人们聚集在一起。你是谁并不重要。
You may identify as a gamer or a part of this fan base or a part of this team. So I think just like we talk about the Olympics being that thing that kind of brings the world together, obviously in competition, but to join ourselves. And that's kind of what e-sports does. So from a university perspective, in my opinion, it's very attractive for a student to feel
你可能认同自己是一名玩家，或者是这个粉丝群的一部分，或者是这支队伍的一部分。所以我认为，就像我们谈论奥运会是那种将世界团结在一起的事情一样，显然是在竞争中，但也是为了让我们团结起来。这就是电子竞技的作用。所以从大学的角度来看，在我看来，学生能够找到一个
that they can find a place that they can belong and identify with. You know, you may feel maybe you're not a greatest football player, maybe you're not a traditional athlete, and this is your thing. You game, like this is what you're good at and this is what you identify with. And it allows you to represent your university in a way that you can be proud of and you can represent in a unique way compared to traditional sports. Absolutely.
他们可以归属并产生认同感的地方是非常有吸引力的。你知道，你可能觉得你不是最伟大的足球运动员，你可能不是传统意义上的运动员，而这就是你的强项。你玩游戏，这就是你擅长的，也是你所认同的。它让你能够以一种你可以引以为豪的方式代表你的大学，并且与传统体育相比，你可以以一种独特的方式进行代表。绝对是这样。
And you touched on one piece in there, which is that it provides a different avenue or culture for support for students as well. So just as we have at most universities, there are many clubs for all of the other. sorts of different kinds of interests. This is another avenue for providing a culture, a way for students to engage with one another, but it goes that one step further in the sense that now there is also a clear purpose that is gaining for these students as part of that activity. Well, and one of the other things that I've seen, and I've had some discussions with some of the
你在其中提到了一个点，那就是它也为学生提供了另一种支持途径或文化。就像我们在大多数大学所拥有的那样，对于所有其他各种兴趣爱好都有许多俱乐部。这是提供文化、让学生相互交流的另一种途径，但它更进一步，因为现在这些学生作为该活动的一部分，也有了一个明确的目标。嗯，我看到的另一件事，我也和一些参与电子竞技的人讨论过，就是我认为在性别基础联赛与非性别基础联赛之间存在的争议。我认为——我倾向于支持的观点是，我们在这一领域拥有公平的竞争环境，我们实际上应该将其视为一个公平的竞争环境，而不是在体育运动中从那种性别歧视的问题开始。你有什么想法吗？不，绝对没有。我的意思是，作为游戏界的一名女性，认同自己是游戏社区中的女性，这并不容易，我相信许多不同背景和身份的人也有同样的感受。然而，我要说的是，游戏已经取得了长足的进步。
folks involved in e-sports, is kind of the controversy that I think it's out there between gender-based leagues versus non-gender-based. And I think the argument, which I kind of fall on the side of, is that we have a level playing field in this area, and we should actually treat it as a level playing field, and not really start with that gender discrimination kind of issues in sports. Do you have any thoughts? No, absolutely. I mean, being a female in gaming, identifying as a female in the gaming community, It is not easy, and I'm sure many people of many different backgrounds and identities feel similarly. However, I will say gaming has come a long way.
人们意识到归根结底，他们想要赢。你想赢得那个分数（SR），你想赢得那个排名，你想成为最好的，归根结底，只要你能赢，你的团队里有谁并不重要。所以我认为这就是我们所追求的，特别是在职业赛场上。我知道他们正在寻求增加多样性。这与女性在STEM（科学、技术、工程和数学）及其他受压迫群体或少数群体在STEM领域面临的问题类似，她们在某种程度上受到排挤，或者在成长过程中对参与这些环境感到犹豫。所以我认为，开放社区并拥有一个多元化和受欢迎的社区——我知道电子竞技联赛正在努力做到这一点，
People realize at the end of the day, they want to win. You want to win that SR, you want to win that rank, you want to be the best, and it really doesn't matter who you have on your team at the end of the day as long as you win. And so I think that that's what we're striving for, especially in the professional scene. I know they are looking at trying to increase diversity. And similar to the problems that women face in STEM and other oppressed groups or minority groups in STEM, where they're kind of pushed down a little bit or they grow up feeling hesitant in engaging in these environments. And so I think that opening up the community and having such a diverse and welcoming community that I know the ESports leagues are striving to do
通过减少毒性等行为并庆祝多样性。所以我认为这就是我们前进的方向，我认为它正在取得进展，我们会到达那里的。我们现在还没到那一步。但在我的经验中，作为我电子竞技组织中唯一的女性主席和联合创始人，你知道，我遇到了一些困难，但我作为组织的门面，尽我所能
by decreasing toxicity and things like that and celebrating diversity. So I think that that's where we're going. and I think it's coming along and we're going to get there. We're not there now. But in my experience, being the female president and the only identified female in my e-sports organization and the co-founder, you know, I've had a little bit of difficulties, but I do my best as a face of an organization
去尝试吸引人们，并说，嘿，我们是欢迎你们的。我们想要你们加入。无论你来自哪里都不重要。如果你热爱游戏并且热爱竞争，我们希望你成为其中的一员。所以在那一点上，一旦人们觉得他们可以认同那个群体，它就会开始增长。非常好。
to try to get people and say, hey, we're welcoming. We want you in. It doesn't matter where you come from. If you love gaming and you love to compete, we want you to be a part of this. And so at that point, it'll start, growing once people feel that they can identify with that group. Very good.
嗯，有趣的是，这不仅仅是电子竞技。也就是说，如果你看看玩游戏的人的比例，基本上是50-50的比例，而且据我所知，在过去10年里，人们一直在收集这方面的数据，情况一直如此。所以这不仅仅是电子竞技，整个游戏在玩游戏的人群方面已经变得更加平衡了。好的。那么现在让我们进入心理学部分吧。
Well, and the interesting thing is that it's not just e-sports. That is, if you take a look at the proportion of people that play games in general, it's basically a 50-50 split and has been for at least that I'm aware of for the last 10 years that people have been collecting data on that information. And so it's not just e-sports, it's gaming overall has become much more balanced in terms of the people that are playing it. Okay. Well, let's get down to the psychology's part now.
绝对的。我们已经完成了关于电子竞技和文化的讨论。你知道，我们，特别是在最近的新闻中，听到了很多人们对游戏的负面看法，我们稍后会谈到这些。但让我们谈谈你从心理学理论和数据中了解到的游戏的积极方面，以及你认为该领域的研究空白在哪里。因为我知道现在，由于它还很新，确实没有太多针对该领域的具体研究。那么你对此有什么看法？
Absolutely. We've done our setup discussing a little bit about e-sports and the culture. You know, we've, especially lately in the news, we've been hearing a lot of the negatives that people perceive about games, and we'll get to those on a little bit. But let's talk a little bit about what you see as the positives in games that we know from psychological theory and from data, and where you see the research gaps in this area. Because I know right now, being as new as it, there's really really. not a lot of specific research in this area. So what are your thoughts on this?
好的，再次说明，我是第21分会的项目主席。第21分会着眼于科学研究，试图了解人们如何与技术互动，这无疑是其中的一个关键要素。所以如果我们想谈论好处，2014年《美国心理学家》（American Psychologist）上有一篇非常重要的论文，由格拉纳赫-拉贝尔（Granach-Labelle）和恩格斯（Engels）撰写，概述了玩电子游戏带来的很长一串好处，从认知影响、情感影响到社会影响。例如，他们概述的一件事是玩电子游戏
Okay, so again I'm program chair for Division 21. 21 looks at scientific research to try and understand how people interact with technology, of which this certainly is a key element of that. And so if we want to talk about benefits, there's a really important paper that came out in 2014 an American psychologist by Granach-Labelle and Engels. that outlines a very long list of benefits that come from playing video games, from cognitive effects and emotional effects and social effects. So, for example, one of the things that they outline is that playing video games
通常会提高空间意识，即理解事物在三维空间中的位置，这对于许多不同的游戏玩法是必需的，特别是对于第一人称射击游戏等游戏。知道你相对于对手的位置，以及你需要射击哪里才能消灭他们，会增加你对自己和周围环境的意识，以及事物之间相对位置的性质。而这之所以如此重要，部分原因在于
oftentimes improves spatial awareness, understanding where things are in three-dimensional space, which is required for a lot of different gameplay, especially for things like first-person shooters. Knowing where you are relative to your opponent and where you need to shoot in order to take them out generates an increase in awareness of you and your surroundings and the relative nature of where things are relative to one another. And part of the reason why this is so important
文献中也有证据表明，这种空间意识的提高与STEM领域的成功高度相关。所以电子游戏可以帮助提高这些认知要素。里面还有很多其他内容，但我把机会留给你，凯蒂。让我为你做一个后续提问。并非所有的电子竞技游戏都是第一人称射击游戏。
is because there's also been evidence in the literature that demonstrates this increase in spatial awareness is also very highly correlated with success in STEM areas. And so it's video games can help improve these kinds of cognitive elements. And there's many more things in there, but I want to provide up to you for Katie. Let me just do a follow-up for you. Not all of the e-sports games are first-person shooters.
不，值得一提。所以，你知道，当然，我只是提到了这一点，因为这是专门衍生出来或专门与第一人称射击游戏联系在一起的。没错。但是的，还有许多其他类型，它们也从游戏中提供了其他好处。是的，是的，他指出了我读过的很多研究，我认为这些研究既出色又需要改进。格林（Green）和贝维（Bévié）在很多方面做了出色的工作，
No, it's well to mention. And so, you know, there's certainly, I was just drawing that up because that's one that has been derived specifically or tied specifically to first-person shooters. Right. But yes, there are many other. genres as well that provide other other benefits from games as well yeah yeah he pointed out a lot of the research that I've read which I think is both excellent and also needs needs improvement great work by Green and Bevié on a lot
关于注意力、空间意识、周边视觉——剧透预警，玩家在这些方面比非玩家更好，但非玩家可以通过数小时的游戏训练变得和玩家一样好。所以作为一名决策研究员，我在想，好吧，但这些选手有时是在不到一秒的时间内做出决策的，是在时间压力下。所以我对那个方面很感兴趣，而那个方面还没有被深入研究。所以我的研究重点是试图了解游戏中的问题解决，以及电子游戏如何影响问题解决技能。现在目前的研究也包括创造力。所以我们发现，非玩家实际上能够从玩
of attentional spatial awareness peripheral vision spoiler alert gamers are better than non-gamers at these things but non-gamers can be trained to become just as good as gamers through hours of gameplay So for me as a decision-making researcher, I'm thinking myself, okay, but these players are making decisions on less than seconds sometimes bases, time pressure-wise. So I'm interested in that aspect, which that aspect has not been delved into a lot. So my research focused on trying to understand problem-solving in games and how video games can affect problem-solving skills. And now currently the study is creativity as well. So what we're finding is that non-gamers actually are able to benefit very greatly from playing
仅仅30分钟的《过山车大亨》（RollerCoaster Tycoon）中获益匪浅，你们观众中可能不到30岁的人，我不确定。我看到观众竖起了大拇指。我们喜欢这个游戏。我相信我们都玩了数百个小时，让我们的父母感到沮丧，但我们可能一直在提高我们的项目管理和问题解决技能。所以再次强调，在我的学科中，我们谈论定义明确的问题和定义模糊的问题。
just 30 minutes of roller coaster tycoon, which those of you in the audience who are maybe less than 30, I'm not quite sure. I see thumbs up from the audience. We loved this game. I'm sure we all played hundreds of hours to our parents dismay, but we may have been increasing our project management problem solving skills. And so again, in my discipline, we talk about well-defined. and ill-defined problems.
定义明确的问题是那些可能只有一个正确解决方案，或者解决方案非常明显的事情。例如，数学题。可能只有一两种方法可以做，这是我们的数学老师试图教我们的，这就是我们解决问题的方法。而且只有一个正确答案。
Well-defined problems are these things that maybe only have one correct solution, or it's a very obvious solution. For example, a math problem. There's maybe one or two ways to do it that our math teachers are trying to teach us, and that's how we solve the problem. And there's only one right answer.
没错。但在现实世界中，我相信我们许多人都经历过定义模糊的问题，这些问题可以从许多不同的方向去处理，有许多不同的解决方案，你仍然可以得出一个好的解决方案、产品或结果。
Exactly. But in the real world, I'm sure many of us experience ill-defined problems, which are problems that can be approached from many different directions, have many different solutions, and you can still come out with a good, solution or product or outcome.
所以在游戏中，很多时候玩家会遇到这些定义模糊的问题。你知道，哦，这个玩家表现得这样，或者这种情况是这样。我有这么多钱，我有这么多领土，我有这么多资源。我可以以多种方式做到这一点。所以我感兴趣的是那些不同的方式是什么，他们在考虑什么，以及为什么他们要考虑这些事情，以及这如何影响现实世界，比如解决问题或提出创造性的解决方案。所以我认为认知的那一个特定领域，
And so in games, a lot of times players are presented with these ill-defined problems. You know, oh, this player is acting this way, or this situation is this way. I have this much money, I have this much territory, I have this many resources. I can do this multiple ways. So what I'm interested in is what are those different ways, what are they considering, and why they're considering those things, and how that impacts something real world, like solving a problem or coming up with creative solutions. And so I think that that area specifically of cognition,
认知是一个非常时髦的词，因为很多人对什么是认知有不同的理解或看法，但我会争辩说，这种高阶认知是游戏研究中所缺失的，在电子竞技中尤其有价值，因为这些是做这些事情的专家。正如肖恩提到的，还有社会层面。我认为有一篇论文在
cognition is I think a very buzzword because a lot of people have a different understanding of our opinion about what cognition is, but I would argue that this higher level cognition is what's missing from games research and especially valuable with e-sports because these are the experts that are doing these things. And as Sean mentioned, the social aspect as well. I think there's a paper in there that's referenced in the
格拉尼克（Granik）的论文中被引用，他们说，人们觉得他们的在线友谊比他们的现实友谊更有价值、更有意义、更有成果。无论是通过爱好建立联系，还是以不同的方式交流，或者一起克服这些困难的问题。所以我发现这一点特别有趣，出自那篇论文。但是是的，那是一篇非常值得一看的论文。家长或想要了解玩游戏有什么好处的人。
in the Granik paper where they say, people feel that their online friendships are more valuable and meaningful and fruitful than their in-person friendships. Whether that's bonding over a hobby or communicating in a different sort of way or getting through these hard problems together. So that I found was especially interesting coming out of that paper. But yeah, that's an excellent paper to look at. Parents or people that want to know about what are the benefits of gaming.
那是一个很好的起点。是的。那么社会层面呢？所以再次强调，大众对玩家的概念是一个独自在卧室里关着灯、整晚都在玩游戏的人。但那不是电子竞技，对吧？不，完全不是，实际上。
That's a great paper to start with. Yes. So what about the social aspects? So again, the popular concept of a gamer is somebody who's by themselves in their bedroom with the lights out and in their gaming all night long. But that's not Eastworks, correct? No, not at all, actually.
我的意思是，好吧，是的，你坐在电脑前，但通常你的队友就坐在你旁边，做着同样的事情。但你几乎是在进行非面对面的对话。所以如果我们都在一个团队里，我说，好吧，这里有一个侧翼攻击，好吧，右边有一个侧翼攻击，你们俩都会听到，你们俩都可以回应
I mean, okay, yeah, you're sitting at a computer, but usually you have your team sitting right next to you kind of doing the same thing. But you're almost having a conversation not face-to-face. So if we were all on a team, and I said, okay, there's a flank coming here, okay, there's a flank coming from the right, you both would hear it, and you both could respond
并沟通回来。显然，这不像我们现在进行的对话，但它是一种沟通水平，现在企业正在进行远程通信。也许你负担不起派你的销售人员去中国，但你可以进行Skype通话，而那种虚拟沟通的概念非常相似。没错。
and communicate back. Obviously, it's not like a conversation we're having right now, but it's a level of communication that now businesses are doing telecommunication. Maybe you can't afford to send your sales guide to China, but you can have a Skype call, and that concept of virtual communication is very similar. Right.
而且你提到的部分内容也是，我们谈论的是职业电子竞技，他们可能在同一个物理位置，只是不一定面向彼此，因为他们通过耳机交谈。但对于休闲电子竞技之类的东西，你仍然在与可能来自世界各地的玩家组成的团队中工作。
And part of what you were alluding to too, is that we're talking about professional e-sports, where they may be in the same physical location, just not necessarily oriented toward each other because they're talking through their headsets. But for things like casual e-sports, you're still working on a team with players that may be from around the world.
所以这不仅是为了那个特定目的而进行的人员沟通和协调，而且通常玩家会在游戏之外，相互协调并谈论他们生活中发生的事情，分享其他元素，这进而增加了文化意识等事物。如果你在和来自世界各地的人交谈，他们可能拥有与你非常不同的视角，而这就是电子竞技可以促进的事情。
So it's not only communication and coordination of people for that particular purpose, but oftentimes players will, outside of the game themselves, coordinate with one another and talk to one another about things that are going on in their life sharing other elements, which then increases things like cultural awareness. If you're talking to somebody that is from around the world, they may have a very different perspective than you are, and that's something that e-sports can facilitate.
好的。所以我还有另一个问题。再次强调，我认为这是一个非常有潜力的广泛研究领域。所以，正如你知道的，我最初的背景是一名军事实验心理学家。我熟悉团队训练研究，以及压力下的决策制定和许多其他研究领域，其中一些涉及模拟，不一定是游戏，所以我们是否正在将这些概念从这些更大的其他领域引入到我们对这些问题的研究思考中？绝对的。我知道很多正在进行的教育研究试图了解学习，并使用游戏、严肃游戏或学习游戏
Okay. So I have another question. Again, I see this as a very potentially broad area of research. So coming from, as, you know, my background originally is a military experimental psychologist. I'm familiar with the team training research so and decision-making under stress and a lot of these other research areas some of which involves simulation not necessarily games so are we drawing on any of those concepts from these bigger other areas into our research thinking on these? Absolutely I know a lot of education research that's being done trying to understand learning it and getting using games serious games or games for learning
有很多不同的术语被使用。但我知道，特别是在军事等领域，航空业自模拟器可能首次制造出来以来就一直在使用它们。我不确定模拟器的历史，但重点是它是一种游戏形式。我会争辩说，模拟在某种程度上可以被视为一种游戏。如果有目标，
There are many different terms for that that are being used. But I know that especially in areas like military, aviation's been using simulations since they were probably first made. I'm not quite sure about the history of simulations, but the point is it's a form of a game. I would argue a simulation to some degree of visual simulation can be maybe considered a game. If there are objectives,
如果有潜在的多个决策点，如果有其他玩家参与。这就引出了一个问题，即什么被视为游戏？所以显然这离电子竞技有点远。但当你进入训练和学习以及潜在的团队建设或领导力发展的概念时，我知道这在军事背景下非常重要，这些概念正在发生。
if there are potentially multiple decision points, if there are other players involved. And so that makes the question, like, what is considered a game? And so obviously that's a little distant from e-sports. But when you get in the concept of training and learning and potentially team building or leadership development that I know is very important in a military context, those concepts are happening.
他们正在为这些选手进行那种训练，因为这是必须发生的。你可能需要有那个是指挥官的人，或者“指挥官”（shot callers）是一个典型的术语。他们做出决定。他们获得信息并做出决定。他们做出指令。所以这可以说是一种需要发展或努力的技能，取决于你团队的动态。
They're doing that training for these players because it needs to happen. You need to maybe have that individual that is the commander or the shot callers is a typical term for it. That makes the decisions. They get the information and they make the decisions. They make the calls. And so that is a skill, arguably, that needs to be developed or worked on depending on the dynamic of your team.
是的。当你谈论电子竞技时，电子竞技选手拥有的技能来自广泛的、可以借鉴现有文献的不同主题领域。所以像专业知识这样的东西已经被研究了几十年。因此，我们可以借鉴那种文献，试图了解某人如何成为电子竞技专家。有趣的是
Yeah. And there's certainly, when you talk about e-sports, the skills that e-sports players have comes from a wide array of different topic areas that can be drawn upon from pre-existing literature. So things like expertise has been, looked at for decades. And so we can draw upon that kind of literature to try and understand how somebody might become an e-sports player expert. The interesting
不过，凯蒂确实提出了游戏可能不完全等同于模拟的论点，但它们非常相似，但我们也必须考虑，电子游戏有什么不同？我们拥有已经存在的文献体系，但你现在可能拥有电子游戏，这是以前没有人真正以那种方式看过的东西。没错。所以有一些基本的感知过程元素，我们了解很多，可以应用于电子游戏。
thing though is that of course Katie made the argument of games may not exactly be the same as simulation but they're very similar but then we also have to consider well what is different about video games and we have this body of literature that already exists but you may have now with video games something that nobody's really looked at in that way before. Right. And so there are some elements of just basic perceptual processes that we know a lot about that can apply to video games.
某人反应有多快？某人能多快看到某物？但我们看待游戏的方式，以及玩游戏的方式，在以前并没有真正得到解决，这是一个完全开放的研究领域。好吧，让我们深入探讨一下。我现在要问你一个难题。所以我们要提出难题。我几乎整个职业生涯都在做技术研究。我在模拟和游戏方面的一个大担忧是，我们对这些游戏或模拟进行研究，但它们非常针对游戏和模拟本身。那么我们的一些研究的普遍性如何？因为再次强调，我20年前做工作时使用的游戏肯定不像今天市面上的游戏，也不会像再过五年甚至更久之后市面上的游戏，所以我们能跨时间说什么？在这些问题上什么具有普遍性，什么真正——所以回到文献，我们谈论的是训练文献，对吧？关于什么能训练、什么不能训练、普遍性和技能特异性，有非常庞大的知识体系。所以这取决于你谈论的是哪种技能，以及普遍性的程度。
How fast can somebody respond? How quickly can somebody see something? But there are ways in which we are looking at games that, in ways in which games are played, that haven't really been addressed before that is a wide open area for research. Well let's get down in the weeds. I'll ask you a hard one now. So we'll pull out the hard questions. So I've been doing technology research almost all of my career. And one of my big concerns in simulation and games is that we do our research on these games or on simulations, but they're very game and simulation specific. So what's the generalizability with some of our
例如，如果你学会了打网球，然后你开始打羽毛球，嗯，一些基本的手眼协调技能可能适用，但该游戏的许多具体细节可能不会很好地推广。没错，所以你在羽毛球中打出的球肯定不会和网球中的完全一样。没错。所以我们在玩游戏时学到的许多技能，一些基本的手眼协调元素可能会迁移，但关于认知，文献对此有点混合，即这些技能到底迁移了多少以及迁移得有多好。好的。不，我同意这一点。
research? Because again, the games that we put when I was doing work on, 20 years ago are certainly not like the games that are out there today and which will not be like the games that are going to be out in another even five years so what can we say across time what what generalizes on these on these issues and what does it really so going back to the literature we're talking for example about training literature right there's a very large body of knowledge about what trains and what doesn't and generalize ability and specificity of skills And so depends a little bit on what kind of skills you're talking about as to the degree of generalizability.
我认为“迁移”（Transfer）这个词是一个大问题。问题解决研究是我们的实验室试图专门回答关于问题解决和创造力这两个能力受游戏影响的问题。以及它们是否可以迁移到所谓的“现实世界”情况或现实问题中。例如，我们使用邓克尔（Dunker）问题，所以它们是类比问题。从表面上看，它们非常不同。有一个医学例子，然后有一个军事例子。解决方案完全相同。
And so, for example, if you learn how to play tennis and then you start taking a badminton, well, some of the basic hand-eye coordination skills might apply, but a lot of the specifics for that game may not generalize very well. Right, so a shot that you play in badminton is certainly not going to be exactly the same one as it is in tennis. Right. And so a lot of the skills that we learn in playing games, some of the basic hand-eye coordination elements may transfer, but a lot of the cognition, the literature is a bit mixed on that as to exactly how much and how well these kinds of skills transfer. Okay. No, I would agree with that.
这是分而治之。所以你要么把射线分开来攻击肿瘤，这给你同样的强度，但显然是从一个组合的角度，要么你把你的部队分散在所有的小路上，这样你的人就不会在雷区爆炸。答案是一样的，但人们被表面特征所困扰。所以我认为人们如何能够处理这些问题并能够看透那些表面特征，无论是，我在模拟中，这就是我正在接受的训练。我在这里看不到现实世界的迁移，他们有那种困难，但有些人
I think the T word transfer is a big problem. The problem solving research is one is our labs attempt to answer that question specifically for problem solving and creativity, the effects of games on those two abilities. And whether or not they could transfer to a, quote, real world situation or a real problem. For example, we use the dunker problem, so they're analogical problems. On the surface, they're very different. There's a medical example and then there's a military example. The solution is exactly the same.
正在突破这一点，并且能够看透这一点并说，这就是我所学到的，无论是心理模型，还是不同的问题解决方式，无论是，我需要考虑这个资源，我需要以不同的方式思考这个资源。游戏提供了那种持续的节奏变化。事情是不同的，并非所有特征都是一样的。你可以控制这一点，这使得它有时成为研究的一个非常好的工具。我们都喜欢控制，这很好。但它也让你看到人们如何能够驾驭环境，并真正利用他们所学到的东西并将其迁移过来。但我认为我们缺乏的是我们如何衡量这种迁移？你知道，你如何
It's a divide and conquer. So you're either dividing the rays up to attack the tumor, which gives you the same intensity, but from obviously a combined angle, or you divide your troops among all of the little roads so your men don't blow up on the mines. The answer is the same, but people get caught up on the surface features. And so I think that how people are able to come at those problems and able to see past those surface features, whether that's, I'm in a simulation and this is what I'm being trained on. I don't see the real world transfer here and they have that difficulty, but there are people
量化，哦，你知道，这是决策制定的迁移，还是这是什么？所以我的另一项研究重点是识别游戏关键点处决策制定的关键线索和方面，并将这些进行分类，我实际上从军事战略、作战和战术决策中提取了一个分类方案，我实际上在足球运动员、守望先锋玩家和英雄联盟玩家中都发现了这些——所以这些类型的决策在不同的背景下发生，但关键是要注意，例如对于迁移，也许是所有这些共同点是什么，或者他们正在使用的趋势和策略是什么
that are pushing past that and are able to see past that and say, this is what I've learned, whether it's a mental model, whether it's a different approach to problem solving, whether it's, I need to consider this resource, I need to think about this resource differently. Games provide that constant change of pace. Things are different, not all features are the same. You can control for that, which makes it sometimes a really great tool for research. We all love control, which is great. But also it allows you to see how people are able to navigate the environment and really take what they've learned and transfer it over. But I think where we're lacking is how do we measure that transfer? You know, how do
他们正在使用这些不同类型的决策来解决这些类型的问题。好的。所以，但是再次强调，我认为决策制定是一项伟大的技能。我认为它适用于不同的事物。它有许多不同的方面，不同的压力。这也包括感知运动方面。你知道，也许你累了，或者也许你意识到你，技术或你自己有问题，你会说，我必须处理这个问题，这将影响我的
you quantify, oh, you know, this is a transfer of decision making or this is this? So my other research is focused on identifying those key cues and facets of decision-making at critical points within a game and categorizing those and I've actually pulled a categorization scheme from the military strategic operational and tactical decisions and so I found those in both football players and in Overwatch players and in League of Legends players so these types of decisions are happening in different contexts but the key is to note for example for transfer maybe is what do all of those have in common or what are the trends and strategies of what
决策制定。所以有很多事情会影响它。所以我认为，我的观点是，决策制定和心理学的其他类似方面将是攻击那个迁移问题的绝佳切入点。好的。好吧。那么再问一个问题。实际上，尽管放马过来。
they're using with these different types of decisions to solve these types of problems. Okay. So, but again, you know, I think decision making is a great skill. I think it applies in different things. There are many different facets of it, different pressures. And that also includes the perceptual motor stuff. You know, maybe you're tired or maybe you're realizing you, there's an issue with a technology or yourself and you're like, I have to deal with this issue and this is going to affect my
是的。实际上，这可能更容易一些。所以再次强调，我的背景中还有其他几个角色。所以我曾共同主持过一个白宫数字游戏委员会一段时间，我还在教育部工作过。但在那些时候，我正在研究教育游戏。我的一位首席研究员（PI）所做的事情之一——我得补充一下，他不是心理学家，但仍然是个好人。华盛顿大学的佐兰·波波维奇（Zorin Popovic），他也做了《Foldit》游戏，所以是一个问题解决游戏。他当时在为我做关于代数和物理以及其他一些领域的教育游戏的工作，而且还
decision making. So there's a lot of things that affect it. So I think, my opinion is that decision making and other similar aspects of psychology would be great to attack that transfer problem. Okay. All right. Another question then. Actually, bring it on.
被盖茨基金会资助。他所做的一件非常有趣的事情是，他采用了《Dragon Box》的一个改编版本，使用了他的一些技术。如果你不知道《Dragon Box》，《Dragon Box》是一款声称——你可以争论这个问题——可以在两小时内教授代数的游戏。
Yeah. Actually, this should be maybe easier. So again, I've had another couple of roles in my background. So I co-chaired a White House committee on digital gaming for a while, and I was at the Department of Education. But during those times, I was looking at educational games. And one of the things one of my PIs did, a non-psychologist, I might add, but still a good guy. Zorin Popovic at University of Washington, who also did the Foldit game, so a problem solving game. He was doing work for me on doing educational games in algebra and physics in some other areas, and also
但它是一款贝里安（Berean）游戏，非常吸引人。但他所做的是，他把游戏拿出来，为整个华盛顿州做了一次全州范围的竞赛。在那之后，他又去了另一个州，然后他做了挪威这个国家。所以包括挪威首相在内的人都在玩这个游戏。所以学习代数。
being funded by the Gates Foundation for this. One of the things he did, which was really interesting, is he took an adapted version of Dragon Box that used some of his technology. And if you don't know Dragon Box, Dragon Box is a game that purports, you can argue about this question, to teach algebra in two hours.
所以我的意思是，你是否认为这些类型的事情也许是我们未来也应该关注的事情，还是我疯了，这完全超出了我们的范围？我认为很多人，我在昨天的座谈会上提到了这一点，很多像消费者或教育工作者这样的人，他们想要那种灵丹妙药，他们想要那种一劳永逸的解决方案。游戏有很多希望。其缺点是游戏需要很多时间，游戏需要很多钱，游戏需要很多资源才能做好。所以如果你没有团队或资源，也许你就做不到。
But it's a Berean game, it's very engaging. But what he did is he took the game out and he did a statewide competition for the entire state of Washington. And then after that, he went out for another state and then he did the country of Norway. So including the prime minister of Norway who was playing this game. So learning algebra.
所以，例如，在我的研究中，我正在看一款Steam上5美元的现成游戏。但其中一些很好。不，不，没错。所以，你知道，如果我们得到——显然，它不是为了教代数，像那样的东西。但有一些游戏，我想它叫TI什么，但它应该教编程的基础知识。TI 100。是的，就是那个。谢谢。你可以看出我在我的Steam库里玩那个游戏玩了多少。
So I mean, do you see these types of things maybe being things we should be focusing on as well down the road for, or am I out of my mind and it's totally out of our ballpark? I think a lot of people, and I mentioned this in the panel yesterday, a lot of people like consumers or educators, they want that magic pill, they want that solution to end all be all. And games has a lot of promise. The drawback of that is that games take a lot of time, games take a lot of money, games take a lot of resources to do it right. And so if you don't have a team or the resources, maybe you can't do that.
但像那样更具体的游戏，但在表面上，你可以看出它更像是一款游戏。我认为隐藏这一点，而不是仅仅让它成为，这是一场教育游戏，因为人们可能会以与对待现成游戏非常不同的方式来对待它。没错。所以，但是不，我不认为——我认为学习游戏和严肃游戏，我认为它们很棒。许多医学模拟非常，或者医学游戏和模拟，结合了模拟。它们很棒。我的意思是，它们很有用。
And so, for example, in my research, I'm looking at an off-the-shelf $5 on Steam game. But some of those are good. No, no, exactly. And so, you know, if we're getting, obviously, it's not meant to teach algebra, something like that. But there are games, I think it's called TI something, but it's supposed to teach the basics of programming. TI 100. Yes, there you go. Thank you. You can tell how much I've played that game in my Steam library.
所以，举个例子，在我的研究中，我正在看一款Steam上售价5美元的现成游戏。但其中一些确实不错。不，不，完全正确。所以，你知道，如果我们得到的是，显然它不是为了教代数之类的东西。但有些游戏，我想叫TI什么的，应该是教编程基础的。TI 100。对，就是那个。谢谢。你可以看出我在Steam库里玩那个游戏玩了多久。
But games like that that are more specified, but are definitely on the surface, you can tell it's more of a game. I think hiding that instead of just having it be, this is an educational game because people may have, approach that very differently than they would a more off the shelf game. Right. And so, but no, I don't think that, I think games for learning and serious games, I think they're great. A lot of medical simulations are very, or medical games and simulate, incorporate simulations. They're great. I mean, they're useful.
但像那样更专业的游戏，表面上肯定能看出它更像是一款游戏。我认为隐藏这一点，而不是直接说这是一场教育游戏，因为人们对待它的方式可能与对待现成游戏的方式非常不同。没错。所以，不，我不认为，我认为学习游戏和严肃游戏，我认为它们很棒。许多医疗模拟游戏，或者医疗游戏和模拟，结合了模拟。它们很棒。我的意思是，它们很有用。
They've demonstrated progress over time in teaching a certain skill, maybe in two weeks to a new surgeon or whatever it is. And they've shown great success. So I think if you have the research backing and you're demonstrating, that whatever field it is or whatever task it is, you're demonstrating learning gains. Nothing wrong with it. And what was interesting about Dragon Box too,
他们已经证明了随着时间的推移，在教授某种技能方面取得了进步，比如在两周内教会一名新外科医生或其他什么技能。而且他们已经展示了巨大的成功。所以我认为，如果你有研究支持，并且你正在证明，无论是什么领域或什么任务，你都在证明学习收益。这没什么错。关于《龙箱》（Dragon Box）有趣的一点是，
at least in the research, and this was an adapted version, so it was not the off-the-shelf version, but they were actually showing some kindergarten or a kindergarten kid solving the challenges in the game. Slower, obviously, than the older kids, but still, amazing that you could actually teach some at least basic algebra concepts to kids that young. young. So really a lot you can do with games. Absolutely. The one caveat though is we have to be
至少在研究中，这是一个改编版本，所以它不是现成的版本，但他们实际上展示了一些幼儿园的孩子在解决游戏中的挑战。当然比大一点的孩子慢，但仍然令人惊讶的是，你竟然可以教那么小的孩子一些最基本的代数概念。所以游戏确实大有可为。绝对是这样。但有一个警告是，我们必须
careful in how they are designed because certainly there's been a lot of research over the years that has demonstrated that if it's not designed in the right way, then whoever is utilizing these educational games may not actually be learning anything. Right. And they may not be motivated. Because that's one of the important elements of games is that in playing a game, there's a there's a lot of motivation from the person playing the game because it's fun. It's enjoyable. And so if they're having a lot of fun and they're actually learning something along with the fun, then there's that added benefit.
谨慎对待它们的设计，因为多年来的大量研究确实表明，如果设计方式不当，那么使用这些教育游戏的人可能根本学不到任何东西。没错。而且他们可能没有动力。因为游戏的一个重要元素是，在玩游戏时，玩游戏的人会有很大的动力，因为这很有趣。它令人愉快。所以如果他们玩得很开心，并且在享受乐趣的同时确实学到了一些东西，那么就有额外的好处。
And so there has to be a careful consideration in terms of the design of that education to make sure that there is the fun driving the motivation and the education comes along with it as opposed to the education with just a little bit of fun, in which case then a lot of people say, you're trying to teach me something, aren't you? and they aren't going to follow through with it necessarily. And so video games have a very big benefit in terms of motivation in terms of continuing on. And I'll give you one example of this.
因此，在教育设计方面必须进行仔细的考虑，以确保乐趣是驱动动力的因素，而教育则伴随其中，而不是只有一点点乐趣的教育，那样的话，很多人会说，你是在试图教我什么，对吧？他们不一定会坚持下去。所以电子游戏在动力和持续性方面有很大的好处。我给你举一个例子。
There's a statistic that was given a number of years ago by a researcher by the name of Jane McGonigal who argued that children in this day and age are spending just as much time, if not more time, playing video games then they actually spend in school. So then the question becomes, well, what are they actually learning from all of this gameplay? Yeah. And so there is potentially a lot of power in terms of the possibility for games.
几年前，一位名叫简·麦戈尼格尔（Jane McGonigal）的研究人员给出了一个统计数据，她认为当今的孩子花在玩电子游戏上的时间，即使没有超过，也至少和他们在学校里花的时间一样多。那么问题就变成了，他们从所有这些游戏过程中到底学到了什么？是的。所以游戏在可能性方面确实蕴含着巨大的潜力。
And adding to that, to the McGonigal argument, they're already doing it. Right. Why would you not leverage it, you know, to some degree, leverage it in a positive way that they can relate to and are motivated by to succeed? And another good example is the psychology of failure. You know, nobody likes to fail. It doesn't feel good. But an example is the Dark Souls series is notorious for being one of the hardest game series. It is punishing.
再加上麦戈尼格尔的论点，他们已经在这样做了。对吧。为什么不利用它呢？你知道，在某种程度上，以一种他们能产生共鸣并有动力去成功的方式积极地利用它？另一个很好的例子是失败心理学。你知道，没有人喜欢失败。感觉不好。但一个例子是《黑暗之魂》（Dark Souls）系列，它以最难的游戏系列之一而闻名。它是惩罚性的。
You know, you see the text, you died every time you died, so you get that reminder every single time, and it sucks. But victory is like a little bit out of your reach. So once you're able to solve that problem ahead of you, you feel good and you're like, I want to keep going. You might die 50 more times, but you're more. but it continuously motivates you to continue to solve those problems. And so similar in a learning game, you know, obviously maybe a little less harsh. You don't need a you failed, you know, maybe necessarily up there. But if you're able to kind of get them right above their capability level
你知道，你每次死的时候都会看到“你死了”（You Died）的文字，所以你每次都会得到那个提醒，这很糟糕。但胜利就在你触手可及的地方。所以一旦你能够解决面前的问题，你就会感觉很好，你会想，我想继续下去。你可能会再死50次，但你更……但它不断激励你继续解决这些问题。所以在学习游戏中也类似，你知道，显然可能没那么严酷。你不一定非得在那儿显示“你失败了”。但如果你能把他们引导到刚好超出他们能力水平的地方，
and they can be so confident once they solve it and they can just want to do more, you know, I solve this, I can do this, I want to learn more. That is what, yeah, that's incorporating that into design. Well, in having funded quite a few games, one of the big problems, which actually we could use, this is a research area in itself for psychology. It's almost impossible to create an engaging game that, if you're doing it for education, that is engaging for a wide variety of students. So I mean, it's very much preferential.
一旦他们解决了问题，他们就会非常有信心，只想做更多，你知道，我解决了这个问题，我能做到，我想学更多。这就是，是的，这就是将其纳入设计。嗯，在资助了相当多的游戏后，一个大问题是，实际上我们可以利用这一点，这本身就是一个心理学研究领域。创建一个引人入胜的游戏几乎是不可能的，如果你是为了教育而做，要让各种各样的学生都觉得引人入胜。所以我的意思是，这非常具有偏好性。
So again, how do you develop a game that goes across cultural divides and gender divides? And I have two kids with autism, so you look at neurotypical. kids. I mean, so the gameplay, the game dynamics, and the themes, I mean, it's, when you look at a game, what most people don't realize, even in the research, is that these are actually a very complex cultural entities in themselves. And it's like studying a complex, any other complex environment in psychology. I'll tell one story since we're talking education, then we'll move on. I was on the America's Army video game development team back in, this was around 2001, using a cutting-edge first-person shooter video game engine. I was very excited they wanted to do medic training.
所以，再次强调，你如何开发一款跨越文化鸿沟和性别鸿沟的游戏？我有两个患有自闭症的孩子，所以你看看神经典型发育的孩子。我的意思是，游戏玩法、游戏动态和主题，我的意思是，当你观察一款游戏时，大多数人没有意识到，即使在研究中，这些实际上本身就是非常复杂的文化实体。这就像研究心理学中任何其他复杂的环境一样。既然我们在谈论教育，我就讲一个故事，然后我们继续。我曾在2001年左右参与过《美国陆军》（America's Army）电子游戏的开发团队，使用的是尖端的第一人称射击游戏引擎。我非常兴奋，他们想做医疗培训。
So I was a medical service corps officer. I said this is going to be great. We're going to have fully interactive. We're going to have them down in there and you're going to be able to treat wounds and it's going to be wonderful. The Army said we want it next week. So what we end up having to do, and this is the worst use of a game platform ever, is we created a classroom and we had the players had to come into the classroom, sit down in a chair, and watch PowerPoint slides of an instructor as they were giving lectures and then pass a test. It was so painful and embarrassing. But what came out of that, we started, and again, this is another area of how powerful
所以我当时是一名医疗服务队军官。我说这太棒了。我们将实现完全互动。我们将让他们深入其中，你将能够处理伤口，这将是美妙的。陆军说我们下周就要。所以我们最终不得不做的是，这是对游戏平台最糟糕的使用，我们创建了一个教室，让玩家必须进入教室，坐在椅子上，观看讲师的PPT幻灯片，听讲座，然后通过考试。这太痛苦和尴尬了。但由此产生的结果是，我们开始，再次强调，这是关于这些东西有多强大的另一个领域。
these can be. About two months after we released it, we got a letter on an email from this kid that said, I saved my brother's life because I had gone through your training program and we were in an accident and he was bleeding. And I was able to stop the bleeding. So I mean, even in these cases, you know, and it was kind of a wake up call for me to see that, you know, how much the, you know,
在我们发布它大约两个月后，我们收到了一封来自这个孩子的电子邮件，他说，我救了我哥哥的命，因为我参加了你们的培训项目，我们发生了一起事故，他在流血。我能够止血。所以我的意思是，即使在这些情况下，你知道，这对我来说是一个警钟，看到，你知道，
one that you could actually get players to go in for a half an hour and hour and sit in a virtual classroom and much, and I was one of the instructors, by the way. So it was my voice, droning on at them. But very lifelike to the Army and Navy experience. But they will you do that. So, you know, these are very interesting things. So.
一方面，你确实可以让玩家进去半小时、一小时，坐在虚拟教室里，而且，顺便说一下，我就是讲师之一。所以那是我的声音，在他们耳边喋喋不休。但对陆军和海军的体验来说非常逼真。但他们会那样做。所以，你知道，这些是非常有趣的事情。所以。
That's great story. So let's, okay, so we've talked for a while. There's usually an elephant in the room about gaming, and especially in these times when we have mass violence situations. And I know some of our listeners are probably asking themselves. So, you know, what are your views? We know that in 2015, the APA released a statement on video games talking about aggression.
那是个很棒的故事。那么，好吧，我们已经谈了一会儿了。关于游戏通常有一个显而易见的问题，特别是在我们面临大规模暴力事件的这些时候。我知道我们的一些听众可能在问自己。所以，你知道，你的观点是什么？我们知道，2015年，美国心理学会（APA）发布了一份关于电子游戏的声明，谈到了攻击性。
We're currently reviewing newer literature, so we'll be discussing that at a later date, what we come out from that. But I've been answering questions here this past week on the differences between violence and aggression, which is a psychological set of constructs that the public doesn't really understand, and kind of rightfully so.
我们目前正在审查较新的文献，所以我们将在以后的日期讨论我们从中得出的结论。但我过去一周一直在回答关于暴力和攻击性之间差异的问题，这是一组公众并不真正理解的心理学概念，某种程度上也是理所当然的。
But where do you stand? So how do you think e-sports compare with other games, or what do you think the overall themes for games? What is your takeaway message from these? I think with e-sports, toxicity has always been a thing in games. As Alexis from our e-sports panel yesterday mentioned, we didn't invent trash talk. Athletes have been doing that for decades. You know, we just kind of do it in a different way, I guess.
但你的立场是什么？你认为电子竞技与其他游戏相比如何，或者你认为游戏的总体主题是什么？你从这些中得到的结论是什么？我认为对于电子竞技来说，毒性在游戏中一直存在。正如我们昨天电子竞技小组的亚历克西斯（Alexis）所提到的，我们并没有发明垃圾话。运动员几十年来一直在这样做。你知道，我想我们只是以不同的方式来做而已。
So I think a lot of times people perceive that level of toxicity or banter as maybe condoning violence or condoning more aggression. And so I think that that is, that is an issue in e-sports, is this outward aggression. They are public figures. You know, rage directed at an individual versus rage directed at the game. In my opinion, those are very different things. You know, against an individual, you know, I'm not super knowledgeable about aggression studies, just specifically aggression and, you know, the correlation or the causation of actually
所以我认为很多时候人们认为那种程度的毒性或戏谑可能是在纵容暴力或纵容更多的攻击性。所以我认为这是一个问题，在电子竞技中，这种外在的攻击性。他们是公众人物。你知道，针对个人的愤怒与针对游戏的愤怒。在我看来，这是非常不同的事情。你知道，针对个人，你知道，我对攻击性研究不是特别了解，只是专门针对攻击性，以及，你知道，实际暴力行为的相关性或因果关系。
violent acts. To me, if you're directing it at an environment, kind of an inanimate thing that doesn't, you know, maybe have any effects, it's kind of one of those coping mechanisms where you go home and you have a bad day and you punch your pillow, and then you feel better, or you cry and you feel better. So I think that this debate is an important one. It's a hot topic, especially for parents. I think a lot of the issue also stems from parents maybe not being as knowledgeable about the games, industry in the field. You know, the ESRB puts out ratings for a reason. You know, a 10-year-old is not
对我来说，如果你把它指向一个环境，一种无生命的、可能没有任何影响的东西，这就像是一种应对机制，你回家后度过了糟糕的一天，你打你的枕头，然后你感觉好些了，或者你哭出来，感觉好些了。所以我认为这场辩论很重要。这是一个热门话题，特别是对家长而言。我认为很多问题也源于家长可能对游戏、行业和领域不够了解。你知道，娱乐软件分级委员会（ESRB）发布评级是有原因的。你知道，一个10岁的孩子不应该
supposed to be playing Counter-Strike, or I think Rainbow Six is also rated them, I'm not sure. But they put those out for that reasons is because they're very easily influenced. And to what degree they're influenced, the developmental psychologists can come in and step in. But I don't know. I think that the studies that have been done have been mixed. I think there was a great panel, I believe, yesterday on violence and games, and the individual went through all of the studies and said, here's how it was designed, you know, here's maybe a potential issue with the methods or how they went about doing it or their operationalization of aggression or violence.
玩《反恐精英》（Counter-Strike），或者我想《彩虹六号》（Rainbow Six）也评级了，我不确定。但他们发布这些评级是有原因的，因为他们很容易受到影响。至于他们受到多大程度的影响，发展心理学家可以介入。但我不知道。我认为已经完成的研究结果好坏参半。我想昨天有一个关于暴力和游戏的很棒的小组讨论，那个人浏览了所有的研究，并说，这是它的设计方式，你知道，这是方法或他们进行研究的方式或他们对攻击性或暴力的操作化定义中可能存在的一个潜在问题。
As I said earlier, it's a very complex social environment. Exactly. And so I think that that, what the APA is doing right now and going through all of the the studies and being able to make a statement. I think as researchers and as people, we need to be skeptical and we need to question those methods and we need to say, okay, so you use this why? Did you justify it? What theory or what research is this based in?
正如我之前所说，这是一个非常复杂的社会环境。没错。所以我认为，美国心理学会目前正在做的事情，即审查所有的研究并能够发表声明。我认为作为研究人员和作为人，我们需要保持怀疑态度，我们需要质疑这些方法，我们需要说，好吧，那么你为什么使用这个？你证明了它的合理性吗？这是基于什么理论或什么研究？
So you can be confident in that. But I think to the public, I think we need to be better about how we're disseminating that information because people may only read one line and that may be the line they remember, that's not your takeaway line. That's not the bottom line up front or whatever it is that you want them to remember. So it's very easy to misinterpret research, especially if you're not projecting it or presenting it in a way that maybe is not able to be understood by a wide audience or misinterpreted. So I think that as a community, maybe we need to do a better job with research,
这样你才能对此有信心。但我认为对公众而言，我认为我们需要在传播这些信息方面做得更好，因为人们可能只读一行，而那可能是他们记住的那一行，那不是你的结论。那不是你想要他们记住的重点或任何东西。所以很容易误解研究，特别是如果你没有以一种可能无法被广泛受众理解或被误解的方式来投射或呈现它。所以我认为作为一个社区，也许我们需要在研究方面做得更好，
being able to disseminate it more clearly with the message that they need to take away from whatever it is, an article or a paper. Right. Well, in addition to that, we're talking about a very complex issue. I mean, it's, but everybody wants a simple answer, right? Is there a connection between violence and video games? And they're looking for yes or no. It's a lot more complicated than that.
能够更清晰地传播它，并传达他们需要从任何文章或论文中获取的信息。没错。嗯，除此之外，我们谈论的是一个非常复杂的问题。我的意思是，它是，但每个人都想要一个简单的答案，对吧？暴力和电子游戏之间有联系吗？他们正在寻找是或否。这比那复杂得多。
And what we need, you know, we're talking about this as science. It needs to be tied back to empirical information that can lend support to which direction. this answer comes from. And then being able to convey it in a meaningful way to the public is really important. There's also issues in terms of not only the content of the games and behaviors that occur, but it's very difficult as psychologists to measure it. There are certainly ethical issues of looking at this kind of topic because as researchers, we can't go into somebody's house and say, hey, play this video game,
我们需要的是，你知道，我们正在将其作为科学来讨论。它需要与经验信息挂钩，这些信息可以为这个答案来自哪个方向提供支持。然后能够以一种有意义的方式将其传达给公众是非常重要的。不仅在游戏内容和发生的行为方面存在问题，而且作为心理学家，衡量它也非常困难。研究这类话题肯定存在伦理问题，因为作为研究人员，我们不能走进某人的家里说，嘿，玩这个电子游戏，
and two hours later we'll see if you want to punch the dog. We can't do that ethically. No. Right. So we have to use these other measures that make it much more difficult to answer that question. But it still needs to be grounded in that research. And the other thing that I find interesting too is that oftentimes a lot of these discussions revolve around a specific genre of games, namely first person shooters.
两个小时后我们看看你是否想打那只狗。我们不能在伦理上这样做。不能。没错。所以我们必须使用这些其他衡量标准，这使得回答这个问题变得更加困难。但它仍然需要以研究为基础。我发现有趣的另一件事是，这些讨论往往围绕着特定类型的游戏，即第一人称射击游戏。
And one of my arguments that I always make that I find it, interesting is that, for example, I play a wide variety of games. Right. So, for example, I may play a fantasy game. So if I am learning how to be violent from that, and the game is on dragons, does that mean tomorrow I'm going out there and being violent against dragons? They don't exist. So how do we map the kinds of activities and behaviors that come from games onto these outcomes that are seen.
我总是提出的一个论点，我觉得很有趣的是，例如，我玩各种各样的游戏。没错。所以，例如，我可能会玩一款奇幻游戏。所以如果我正在从中学习如何变得暴力，而游戏是关于龙的，那是否意味着明天我要出去对龙施暴？它们不存在。那么我们如何将来自游戏的活动和行为映射到所看到的这些结果上呢？
It's an extraordinarily complex problem. Yeah, and I'll just end it with the caveat that, you know, research-wise, we have, some of the research we've seen does purport small increases in aggression, not a huge effect size, but we have not seen any research that actually relates games to violence, to extreme violence. And I think that's the take of them. And their correlational studies typically, not causal. And to that point, I think, you know, it's easy to talk about the negative, very easy to talk about the negative and ignore the positive.
这是一个极其复杂的问题。是的，我最后要加一个警告，你知道，从研究角度来看，我们有一些，我们看到的一些研究确实声称攻击性有小幅增加，效应量并不大，但我们没有看到任何研究真正将游戏与暴力，与极端暴力联系起来。我认为这就是结论。而且它们通常是相关性研究，而不是因果性研究。说到这一点，我认为，你知道，谈论负面影响很容易，谈论负面影响并忽略正面影响非常容易。
Right. You know, there have been studies that I've looked at where they actually have found an increase in pro-social behavior, such as interacting with individuals of different cultures, going out into the community and volunteering, civilian or civic activities, an increase, and obviously these are self-report. You know, they're not going out stalking people, but self-reported increase in, these types of pro-social behaviors or attitudes or feelings. And so that, you know, those are, those types of studies need to be continued, but they're also being kind of pushed down by this, you know,
没错。你知道，我研究过一些研究，他们实际上发现了亲社会行为的增加，例如与不同文化的人互动，走进社区并做志愿者，平民或公民活动，有所增加，显然这些是自我报告。你知道，他们并没有出去跟踪别人，但自我报告显示这些类型的亲社会行为或态度或感受有所增加。所以，你知道，那些，这些类型的研究需要继续，但它们也被这种，你知道，
we're in a culture of violence and a lot of hate, you know, in the world. And so that's very easily overshadowed. You know, it is an issue. You know, violence is definitely an issue. You know, maybe even more important than potentially, you know, pro-social behavior, increasing pro-social behaviors. but maybe there's a mitigating factor there. Maybe there's something we're missing
我们处于一个充满暴力和仇恨的文化中，你知道，在世界上。所以这很容易被掩盖。你知道，这是一个问题。你知道，暴力绝对是一个问题。你知道，可能比潜在的，你知道，亲社会行为，增加亲社会行为更重要。但也许那里有一个缓解因素。也许我们错过了一些东西，
that we can leverage in games that are promoting that, potentially preventing some of these things that happens. I think that's a perfect place to stop, so I'll ask one more question, and this is a short answer essay, or not even an essay. What's your favorite game?
我们可以在游戏中利用这些东西来促进这一点，可能防止一些发生的事情。我认为这是一个完美的停止点，所以我再问一个问题，这是一个简短的回答，甚至不是一篇论文。你最喜欢的游戏是什么？
Oh, you're killing me here. Can we just end it now? It's going to be hard. Love Portal, but mine's actually a tie. Super Metroid and Castlevania Symphony of the night because of the same style of gameplay. Okay. Are we talking current or past?
哦，你这是要我的命啊。我们现在能结束吗？这很难。喜欢《传送门》（Portal），但我的其实是并列的。《超级银河战士》（Super Metroid）和《恶魔城：月下夜想曲》（Castlevania Symphony of the Night），因为它们是同一种游戏风格。好的。我们是在谈论当前还是过去？
Your entire life. That's not possible. That's like asking a book reader. Okay, current. I play a lot of Heroes of the Storm. I love that game. I also love the persona series and the Fire Emblem series. So, yeah, go out and buy them.
你的一生。那是不可能的。那就像问一个读书的人。好吧，当前的。我玩很多《风暴英雄》（Heroes of the Storm）。我喜欢那个游戏。我也喜欢《女神异闻录》（Persona）系列和《火焰之纹章》（Fire Emblem）系列。所以，是的，去买它们吧。
No, I'm not sponsored by any of these companies, but they're excellent game. And persona is based in psychology. Those of you that know what a persona is, I want to know about yourself. But there are lots of great games that are good research platforms. Absolutely. Curbel Space Force is often overlooked. But there's lots to be done in this area. So we really encourage everybody who's listening to kind of go out, learn more about these areas, not just in e-sports, but games overall.
不，我没有被这些公司中的任何一家赞助，但它们是出色的游戏。《女神异闻录》是基于心理学的。你们中那些知道什么是人格面具（Persona）的人，我想了解你们自己。但有很多很棒的游戏是很好的研究平台。《坎巴拉太空计划》（Kerbal Space Program）经常被忽视。但在这个领域有很多事情要做。所以我们真的鼓励每一位听众走出去，更多地了解这些领域，不仅是电子竞技，还有整个游戏。
Because there are some really fascinating research areas across the spectrum of psychology that you can really pursue. So thank you for listening. Thank you for your informative discussions. Thank you for having us. Thank you. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因为在心理学的整个范围内，有一些非常迷人的研究领域，你可以真正去追求。所以谢谢你们的收听。谢谢你们的信息丰富的讨论。谢谢你们邀请我们。谢谢。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。